[Musique]
nous
la famille doit est en vacances à la
montagne il semblerait que cette
émission est donné des idées aux enfants
[Musique]
hi hi hi hi lui croit s'être équipé
comme de vrais alpinistes sans rien dire
à personne ils partent à l'assaut de la
montagne
[Musique]
pacôme
et en plus il pleut
avec une corde à sauter quelle idée là
prendre entre ses dents
[Musique]
oui mais ne veut pas parler
à toi credo chats les aubettes couches
du secours auprès de ses parts
[Musique]
mais attention je ressens tu étouffes
credo chat
[Musique]
à
il
mon credo chat
[Musique]
la corde sur le couteau tranchant plus
ce qu'est la prudence il était temps
[Musique]
oh
ça y est tu en auras encore prendre la
direction des opérations
il n'est pas équipé non plus est d'abord
une icône est rien
[Musique]
voilà credo chat et sauver ton doit
aussi d'ailleurs
[Musique]
à
faites attention
la montagne peut être dangereuse soyez
prudent renvoi watteau
[Musique]
et